La volta al món a peu, dia 282.
Això és Volúncul.
Cap allà no és.
És cap allà.
És que...
No hi ha res, eh?
És que, clar,
menys 63 graus a l'hivern, saps?
Ja em diràs.
Ja em diràs qui viu aquí.
Doncs viu gent, viu gent.
Bueno, avui els alemanys van al llac
i jo segueixo la meva ruta avui.
Bye.
Avui vaig a l'inxul.
Avui dia de descans.
Avui dia relax.
35 quilòmetres.
Sí, sí.
Clar, és que no es pot comparar amb els dies anteriors
perquè 35 quilòmetres són bastant menys.
I, a més, avui torno a la Pamir Highway.
Ostres, Enric, ja s'ha acabat.
Ja s'ha acabat això.
Doncs sí.
Sí, sí, m'ho he passat ràpid.
Encara són uns quilòmetres
en terreny així.
O sigui, Terra.
I després torno a la Pamir
i 35 quilòmetres fins a l'inxul.
Molt bé. Som-hi.
Bon via.
Bon dia.
Fins demà!
És 11 i mitja, estava sent un matí sense vent ni res i de cop i volta han aparegut aquests núvols
i ha començat a bufar el vent, una barbaritat, no he hagut de posar això, els guants...
I és que el vent que bufa és fred, eh?
Per això també no estic gravant gaire perquè, clar, trobar el mòbil és una mica complicat.
Bueno, us ensenyo que estic en un llac ara, un llac que està com bastant sec
i això entenc que és sal, això blanc.
Guapíssim! I ara sí que estic al típic lloc que t'imaginies del Pamir, no?
Que és una esplanada...
...gegantina de res amb muntanyes al fons.
És complicat caminar pel vent i el vent fred.
I és monòton i mentalment es fa bastant dur.
Però em recordo a mi mateix que és un paisatge únic i potser no torno a veure'l mai més a la vida.
No es veu però allà, a la base d'aquesta muntanya d'aquí, hi ha l'autopista, la Pamir.
D'aquí uns pocs quilòmetres ja l'enllaçem.
és de la Més de 30 anys.
Tornarem a fer-ho, ja que l'Espanya està en una època en què les pengem FAQs,
i és una de les més importants decisions de la història d'enllamament.
Com es pot fer el desig de persones?
A les escoles de Sant Jordi, la gent fa molta feina i l'Espanya ha tingut la lluita d'aquesta crisi.
I la resta n'ha fet molt bé.
Amb la investidura en els 21 milions d'euros d'euros,
l'Espanya està altra vegada més enllat,
Veig aquí un parell de bicis abandonades. Els hi podria robar aigua.
On deuen estar?
Bandera de...
Quina bandera és aquesta?
República Txeca?
Ei! Estan allà.
Hello. Anem a saludar.
Doncs sí, eren txecs.
Però no els he fet entrevista perquè tampoc m'he quedat molta estona
perquè, ostres, ha començat a...
em fa una mica d'aire
i dic, ui, millor em començo a moure.
La bandera
resulta que és així una mica
que no sembla la bandera txeca
perquè la van comprar a Vietnam
i a Vietnam no deuen saber
com és la bandera txeca, no ho sé.
Que venen de Vietnam.
De Vietnam, en bicicleta fins aquí
i la seva intenció és tornar a la República Txeca.
Buf, no vull imaginar-me
el fred que passaran aquests senyors, eh?
Ja, ja fins al Uzbekistan,
o sigui, al darrere del Uzbekistan
i Kazakstan, ja pots fer rasca
però és que després a Turquia
a l'hivern fa una rasca que flipes, eh?
Ojo, a Turquia a l'hivern, eh?
Que a un es pensa que és un lloc així
desert, però
tant al nord com al centre fa molt de fred.
Bueno, és igual, queden 17 quilòmetres
vull dir, no queda tant
i com veieu, vaig canviant de capa constantment
primer començant al paravent
després m'he posat la jaqueta, que ara està a dintre
i ara això, que en realitat és el que hauria
començat des d'un bon principi, perquè
la peça, la roba, que més
que millor regula la temperatura, no?
Si fa molt de vent, no.
Molt de vent és complicat i potser m'he de posar
al paravent, però si no, està perfecte.
Bueno, tu
doncs res, seguim
no hi ha molt més a dir, ni molt més a fer
és tot
és tot això.
És increïble.
Actualització a les 5 de la tarda
han caigut fins i tot
4 gotes fa una estona.
Bueno, ja veig allà
Alitxur, crec que es pronuncia Alijur.
Però bueno, aquí ho tenim.
També veig uns animals
d'aquí, no sé si seran vaques
o llacs, ara veurem.
I bueno, no sé si es veu al vídeo, però
és una ciutat, un poble més aviat
bastant llarg
el meu
Guesthouse Homestay està al final
de tot, per tant, em queden
només 5 quilòmetres per caminar.
Està molt bé.
Bueno, ostres, això és un joc
inhòspita.
Deixat de la mà de Déu.
Jo no he de viure aquí, tio.
O sigui, estem a principis de setembre
i ja estem així, eh?
Com deu ser
el desembre, febrer?
No sé, potser no viuen aquí.
Potser no dius que viuen aquí ara.
Però és veritat que avui fa un dia especialment de gossos.
Si us en recordeu,
ahir va fer molt bon dia
no feia ni un núvol
avui ha fet aquest dia
demà en teoria torna el sol
però bueno, la primera impressió és
faaa
heavy metal, eh
bueno, vaig a
aquí hi ha un market, crec que n'hi ha un altre també per ahir
a provisionar-me una mica
de menjar pels propers dies
encara que realment no he gastat
gaire aquests dies perquè
pensava que trigaria tres dies a fer el tram aquest
i he trigat dos
per tant tinc bastant menja
bueno, doncs sembla mentida però
aquest edifici així
una mica
marró de les vores
és el Hostel
Marco Polo
Hostel Guesthouse
final és
pur marketing
estic cansat
d'aquest vent
cansat de les cames i cansat de tot
a veure si
si tenen lloc i tot va bé
el lloc deu ser bastant concorregut
perquè deu estar bé
que crec que les habitacions s'han acabat
una llàstima
podria haver anat a buscar un altre
un altre hostel
o un altre guesthouse
però no, no he volgut
perquè m'han ofert això
dormir aquí dintre
i tu diràs, ostres quina rasca
bueno
m'han dit que hi ha una calefacció
anem a veure
que han engegat la calefacció
primer m'he de trobar les sabates
a veure el lloc mola molt
jo mai he estat a un lloc així
això es diu una llurtre crec, no?
una llurtre
i aquí hi ha aquesta calefacció
bueno
el llit estaré tapat
i si estic sol doncs mira
això
està bé, estic sol, crec que sí
aquí la gent
no són com els tagics
ni com la gent del Pamir
que hem vist ara, no, no
aquí són la cara
les faccions són com
xinesos o casacs
o de Mongòlia
o sigui amb els ulls molt
molt així, no?
m'ha sorprès, no m'ho esperava
perquè realment no estem tan lluny
de Horok, que és el poble que jo vaig descansar
i canvia completament
la pel·lícula
suposo que deuen parlar també un altre idioma
bueno, vale
hi ha una noia que està a punt de dutxar-se
i després vaig jo
avui he acabat
abans, són les
bueno, ara són les 6 però he arribat a les 5
llavors està bé una mica de descans
perquè l'etapa de demà
després us ho explico
bueno, ja m'he dutxat
dutxa millor del previst
ha sortit l'aigua calenta durant
5-10 minuts que he estat allà
sense problema
perquè a vegades rotllo para, no?
s'acaba l'aigua calenta, no, no, no
he sortit, he pogut netejar la roba i
amb el fred que fa l'aigua calenta em troba de luxe
ara toca sopar
no som ni de 7
què tenim? tenia amanida, meló
jo no entenc si això és a l'esmorzar també
ja l'han posat, perquè hi ha galetes
hi ha marmelada, hi ha
dolços, hi ha síndria
hi ha per picar, fruita
i bueno, sí
hi ha bastanta gent, hi ha bastanta gent, veig
unes 10 persones occidentals
i després 3 d'aquí al costat que semblen guies
i bueno, suposo que em portava
una sopa o una mica de carn
o algo així
eh, sí, sembla que sí
sembla que sí
molt bé, tu
doncs, mira, aquí està la sopa
thank you very much
vale, doncs
vaig a sopar i després fem resum
ja he sopat
estic aquí al meu llit
a la meva llurtre privada
tinc aquí el radiador
també, i he posat la roba interior
aixuga a sobre
no, Enric, no has de posar
res a sobre el radiador, tal
no passa res
jo sempre que vaig a un hotel, a l'hivern sobretot ara ja no
la roba la posava a sobre el radiador
i no passa res
el que passa és que potser no ho tinc tota la nit
potser aquí una estona ho trec i ja està
ai, bueno, un dia molt estrany
un dia molt estrany
la sensació de caminar per aquesta carretera
amb aquests paisatges
oberts
herms
i el fet de dir avui només tinc 37 km
tal, que és el que he fet
37 km
ha sigut un dia estrany
també una mica durillo, eh, per
no tant per la monotonia, que dius, va
ho passes escoltant la ràdio, música, tal
sinó pel
pel vent
i el vent fred
ha sigut un dia una mica empenyador en aquest sentit
demà i passat al principi fa millor
temperatura
re cap refresc, el té
de sopar
i de diners, doncs 25 euros d'això
i 8 euros al supermercat
aquí és que no
no és barato, eh, parlar no he parlat amb ningú
bé, no, ah, bueno sí
amb els dos xecs, dues persones
a veure
informació important
queden dos trams
per acabar a Tajikistan
primer tram des d'on estic ara
a Lihur
fins a Murgab
i segon tram des de Murgab fins a
Kulmapass, frontera amb la Xina
val, primer tram
aquest primer tram són 100 km
des d'aquí fins a Murgab
5 km, 100 km
amb res entre mig
res, bueno, crec que hi ha un
restaurant a 10 km d'aquí
o poc
però ja està, després són, doncs això
100 km, 90 km d'absolutament res
com m'ho afronto això?
podria fer dos dies de 50 km
o dividir-ho
en tres dies
i demà sortir una mica més tard perquè estic aquí
a la
aquesta
i tal, a veure
intentaré fer els dos dies de 50
intentaré fer-ho
perquè al final és pla
i és carretera que s'avança ràpid
no és descabellat fer 50 km
però serà dur, pesat
crec que no hi ha internet de res ni res
però bueno
és que
tres dies també es fa durillo
el problema és que clar
quan estàs a una guesthouse o a un lloc així
costa llevar-se molt d'hora perquè
et posen l'esmorzar tal
jo ho intentaré
a veure, demà intentaré posar-me a caminar
abans de les 7
no, a les 6 i mitja
m'agradaria posar-me a caminar
és difícil
és fàcil de dir però difícil de fer
però sí, ho intentaré
i bueno sempre hi ha l'opció de si no em veig capaç
doncs acampo
i el segon tram doncs ja us explicaré
quan arribi
Tadjikistan aquest tram final
s'està fent dur
vénen dies encara durs, dos dies de 50 km
moltes coses
però únics
llocs únics
vinga, bona nit